lors de ce premier tour de la
présidentielle 2022 dans les yvelines
les électeurs de gauche ont concentré
leur vote sur un seul candidat jean-luc
mélenchon un vote utile qui a fait
s'effondrer les résultats des partis de
gauche traditionnelle europe ecologie
les verts ressort avec 5 points 49 % de
voix le parti communiste français avec
1,59 % de voix devant le parti
socialiste avec seulement 1,23 pour cent
on a tous le l'impact du vote du vote
utile deux derniers jours c'est un
résultat attendu pour ce qu'elle fit le
temps de regarder attentivement les
études d'opinion qui précède la maison
des élections présidentielles on savait
qu'on allait fiasco s'est réduite je
suis pas étonné sauf que j'espérais
autre chose que des écologistes qui se
sont laissés
entraîner par le vote utile en faveur de
jean-luc mélenchon face à de tels scores
certains affirment vouloir peut-être
réfléchir un nouveau parti de gauche
plus unis d'autres n'y voient pas
d'intérêt sous dire qu'il faut même pas
présenter des candidats de premier tour
lors d'une échéance aussi importante que
la présidentielle parce qu'il faut
impérativement assurer la qualification
d'un seul candidat de gauche c'est
finalement renoncé à l'idée que des
failles politique entière des courants
de pensée alors de vie politique
française puisse présenter des candidats
les relations entre la france a soumises
élevés qui sont globalement pas très
bonne chaque ado
continuer comme ça qu'on veut que
l'écologie et la justice sociale soient
les prochaines jd fortune à venir les
responsables de gauche dans les yvelines
se rassemblent tout de même sur un point
ils appellent tous à faire barrage au
rassemblement national et à voter pour
emmanuel macron en vue du second tour le
24 avril des statines chez nous appelle
à voter pour le président accuse non pas
par adhésion je suis j'espère que chacun
d'eux avant grand regret
oui je vais dire ça je veux dire que
j'appellerais plutôt un 20e match et
macro et les communistes ont toujours
été très claire par rapport à hobart
achever à l'extrême droite voter macro
ne veut pas dire votez pour macron et
ses réformes mais pour empêcher la
l'extrême droite d'arrivée au pouvoir on
ne joue pas du cucs en droite jamais
dorénavant le parti socialiste le parti
communiste français et europe ecologie
les verts se concentre sur une nouvelle
échéance les législatives un enjeu
primordial pour ces partis de gauche
traditionnelle